If you're just
starting out in
Commander or looking for
easy decks to
build, look no
further: here are three
commanders
that are easy to
strategize around and
will help you
learn the game.  In no
particular order,
first up we have
Yaroka, the Defiler.
I will make a small
introduction.  Yaroka is
the most expensive card in the
entire video, currently
it costs about
$10.  But the rest of the
cards included in the
deck are so
cheap that it
makes up for the cost.
So, this
3/5 Sultai Elemental Horror for
five mana only cares
about one thing.  About things that
go out on the
battlefield.  Yaroka has a "
deadly touch"
and a "connection with
life."  If
a permanent that
enters the
battlefield activates an
ability of a permanent
you control,
that ability
triggers an
additional time.  So,
essentially, if we have
Yaroka on the battlefield and we
cast Ravenous
Chupacabra, its ability
when it enters the battlefield
triggers twice.
This way, we
can destroy two
different creatures.  Thanks to the
Sultai colors
that Yaroka gives
us access to, nothing is impossible in this
deck
.
Destroy any
type of permanent.
Take a look at these maps
.  Reclamation Sage, Acidic Slime,
Yuriko, the Tiger's Shadow, Woodfall
Primus—it's easy.
No problem.  We
have Wood Elves, Risen Reef, and
even Lotus Cobra.
Canceling spells
and abilities.  Hmm, that's
easy.  We have Draining Whelk
, Aboleth Spawn and Venser, Shaper
Savant.  Get the cards?  This is
easy with
cards like
Coiling Oracle and Tatyova, Benthic
Druid.  You can even
quickly end the game
with End-Raze
Forerunners.  And if that
wasn't enough, you play your
best three
colors to
protect your
commander and find
any answer.
Next we have Taland, the
Summoner of Heaven.  Before we
look at this
map, I want
to emphasize: don't
let anyone in
your Commander group
talk you out of
playing blue.
Sure, some may
grumble, but it's
part of the game, just like any
other color.
Blue has a
bad reputation
for being
seen only as
cancellations and
extra moves,
but it goes much deeper than that.
So here's a deck
based on
cancellations and
extra moves, because that's all
I could
think of.  I'm kidding,
of course.  So, Taland,
Caller of Heaven is a
2/2 creature for four
mana that says: "
Whenever you
cast an instant
or
sorcery, create a
2/2 blue dragon token with flying
."  For Taland, the
game plan is simple, and support cards are
quite cheap for him.  We
try to
cast
spells, draw
cards, and summon
a bunch of annoying
birds.  Let's start with
Murmuring Mystic and Talrand, Sky
Summoner, which are just
slight
variations of
Talrand himself.  There are also
cards like Metallurgic
Summonings, Shark Typhoon, and
even Ominous Seas that
fit perfectly
into this token theme.
If we're going to
create all these
creatures with flying, it's
worth adding
Favorable Winds and Windstorm Drake as well.
Windreader Sphinx is an
obvious choice for
additional
card selection.  Blue has
no problem with this
.  Here are some of the
most profitable
card selection options you can
use in your
deck.  Winged Words, Brainstorm,
Treasure Cruise, Consider, Frantic
Search, Fact or Fiction.  I could go on and on about the
list
for protection.  There is
no shortage of blue in this either.
Counterspell, Negate, Rewind, Wizard's
Retort, Unwind, Disdainful Stroke.
They
will definitely help you get
started
casting all those
spells.
Cards like Font of Magic, Arcane
Melee, Jace's Sanctum, and Lier,
Disciple of the Drowned can
be very
useful.  I could go on
as this deck is
very easy to put together.  And
the best part is the
land base.  These are
practically just
islands.  Next we have
Torbran, Thane of Red Fell.  There was always one rule in my
old group of
commanders
that I will never forget.    A
fast game is a good
game, and boy does
Thorbran agree with that.
Torbran is a
four-mana 2/4 creature that makes
all
red springs
you control
deal two
more damage.  This
means that each of
your creatures deals an
additional two points of
damage in combat.  Any
triggered or
activated abilities
that deal damage
deal an additional
two points.
Planeswalkers,
instant spells,
sorceries.  If it is
red and deals
damage, it does so more
strongly.  The idea of ​​this
deck is very simple.
Just cause
damage.  Among the creatures
we have the likes of Defiler of
Instinct, Kessig Flamebreather,
Thermo-Alchemist, Firebrand Archer,
Guttersnipe, and Tectonic Giant.
Torbran, God of Fury is
simply great here,
as the
over-damage condition
also gets a bonus
from Torbran, even
if the original
source already got a
bonus;  The selection of cards to
upgrade your hand is very
important.  Therefore, Magus of the
Wheel, Big Score, Tormenting Voice,
Cathartic Reunion, Seize the Spoils
and Wild Guess ensure
that you hold a full
hand.  And when you've
burned everyone out and you're
running out of resources,
Past in Flames and Mizzix's Mastery
allow you
to make a final
dash to end the
game.  Don't forget
to add your
direct
damage spells like Comet Storm,
Electrodominance, and Banefire.  And
also your mass
destructions like Chain
Reaction, Burn Down the House, and
Blasphemous Act.  Well, here are three
deck ideas to
get your
creativity going.  If
you want to see a
full review of
any of these maps, let
me know.
Be sure to like
if you want to
collect one of these
decks.  Thanks for
watching, see you
next time.